[Music]
so whenever you talk about astralis
the first name that has to come to mind
has to be device
australis always does well but they have
this curse of getting to the semifinals
and then never being able to move
forward
they had this classic storyline they
would choke they would get nervous
it's the old narrative where they're you
know they're the chokers or the guys who
can never make it here because they
always collapse
i know that they always choke and they
always fail when people would say oh we
can expect them to choke now
the introduction of a sports
psychologist for australis also very
important with their history of
choking up until the earlier part of
this year
one of the main things that
characteristic we would have described
devices
is a choker he'd be the one who choked
device what are you doing device he
should know he sees alois while he's he
spots both on he gets oh my god
that is insane what a next level play
and it looks like device just like in
the pistols it's gonna stop the play and
he picks up the kill so go with it
device oh the device is in the back and
you can do so much damage from here
you can see he can hide from the
follow-up players he gets another one
and astralis and they finish it off
[Music]
[Applause]
watch how i break through the ceiling
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
nikolai device reads was born in viola
denmark on september 8th
1995. from a young age he demonstrated a
natural talent
for not only playing games but mastering
them
honestly i think my first memory of
counter-strike was when like
we had like that after school club when
i was like eight or nine years old where
like people were playing some shooting
game and i was watching a little bit i
wasn't that interested in video games
right at that point when i was
that age but i tried it out and people
were kind of
shocked and started calling me a cheater
and i was a little kid and
30 year old would like people will come
and check my computer for cheats when i
was at a land tournament and so on
in addition to being an avid
counter-strike player he also became
truly gifted at badminton
he was playing at the the top level team
in
our city one of the big clubs in denmark
was asking if he would play with them
but he said no i think i was
i was always very competitive like as a
person i played batman on a pretty high
level
and i also played cs at the same time so
i kind of chose to pursue badminton a
little bit more in the beginning
when i was like in my early teenage
years but at one point
i just realized that i was really good
at counter-strike and i had to
to like challenge myself in another way
by 2011
the 15 year old dane was considered a
top-tier talent
in danish counter-strike source and was
given a chance to play
for one of the region's best teams the
copenhagen wolves
do you think this guy's got a great
future up for like
one and a half year ago i definitely
thought he was cheating but
after been boot camping and playing with
him at this land i'm sure that he is
the next to we should be careful for but
his time and energy were split between
his two passions
the traditional sport that he was
expected to pursue
and the esport in which he'd become not
only tremendously talented
but spiritually invested device knew
that something had to give
and after two years of indecision being
kicked from the wolves over his
inability to commit
and a sports injury he knew that the
time had come
to shift his focus to counter-strike it
was always like a 50-50 for me and in
the end it was an
injury in the knee that made me decide
i'm really good at this counter-strike
game i should continue with that
come 2013 device had rejoined the wolves
and it was here he would meet two of the
most important
and long-standing teammates of his
career peter dupree
rasmussen and andreas zypix husleth
and within a matter of weeks device was
showcasing his talent against some of
europe's best
yeah they're not gonna be i mean they
could still obviously increase the lead
to eleven
four but they're not gonna ginormous
lead from it
just picking up kill after kill here on
the outside there's his fourth
device is now 15 and 5. but the question
was whether the prodigious dane was
ready to commit to counter-strike
full-time
device went on to spend roughly nine
months with the wolves and was removed
and re-added to the roster twice
on account of his inability to show up
to practice it was during the month of
cs go's very first major at dreamhack
winter 2013
that device decided to get serious he
joined the wolves for the fourth and
final time
as they prepared for their last hurrah
at the biggest tournament
cs go had ever seen they took out one of
the big dangerments if they can follow
it up
well they lose dupreeh they lose two
more what a turnaround
very games have three and copenhagen
walls have just two players left
standing he took a bit of damage but
he's still standing and he'll push
through zip nicks is out it's all on
nico
as he looks to hold copenhagen walls in
this tournament he dances back he's got
just smith's on 27 points to help
he's going to move in now can't see him
can't see him
looks for the frenchman has a guess he's
going to try and bait him out with the
defuse
and pushes around the corner oh smith
gets it
the romance is over the french have gone
through
the danes emerged from the tournament
with a fifth eighth finish and were
convinced that they'd finally found the
right chemistry they needed to win
and though they were unable to
renegotiate their contracts with the
wolves
the roster opted to play under their own
banner uber geeks
uber geeks quickly established
themselves as one of denmark's strongest
rosters
and were picked up by team dignitas
several months before cs go's second
major
in katowice we are extremely thrilled
about joining team deaconesses and we
have high hopes and expectations for
this project and to that unfortunately
in general
we look forward to representing dignitas
in the future and we hope that our
cooperation will bring
both lots of good experiences and
memories and we're really happy that we
can finally announce that we are
arriving
after finishing first in their group the
danes managed to topple hellraisers in
the quarter-finals
before meeting a dominant ninjas in
pajamas in the semis
three on three here let's get right it's
waiting for a fish picks up one they
actually picks up a second but get right
finally turns around picks up the guy
into maine i know it's a one-on-one
device with two hp
that right with full i'm not looking for
the kill set it's not down to 46 hp
5's gonna come in and actually get the
kill what an outplay by device he's
gonna get the defuse officers he gets it
no
oh oh nice push in the hood here exists
he's right in front of him he's gonna
spot him out let's get the kill until
look for the second he will pick it up
as well not before getting dinged up but
fiverr gets taken down
get right comes in though gets the kill
and is it next match down to two hp now
friday gonna come in gonna pick up one
get right gonna pick up another one as
well and they are just shredding through
them that nade
completely tore them a new one all the
hands are the pre and fetish all blocked
by ramp force it's taken down though
that is that potential push coming in
secretly around the corner looking for
that kill gets to pre-done at really low
health
but they cleaned it up that is nip
picking up the two of victory
little did the danes know their loss to
nip would be the first in a long line of
quarter and semi-final eliminations
but 2014 was still a breakout year for
device
as he managed to make an appearance on
hltv's list of the top 20 players of
2014
but his best was yet to come
in the days following their fifth eighth
finish at dreamhack winter 2014
dignitas decided that the time had come
for a change
out went fetish and in came another
danish igl
one who is expected to take the now
closely knit core of device dupre and
zipics
to the next level i think actually on
this team he's the new guy but crucially
as the in-game leader we've already
known that dignitas have the skills
they've got all these fraggers these
really skilled players but they've never
had like the unit they've never been the
cohesive team and the teams that beat
them
are the ones who have the tactics and
they know how to win t-shirt rounds and
this is the change that they really need
especially when they always they always
do good in groups they tend to uh to
choke a little bit during the
the playoffs uh just a little bit uh and
then maybe bringing in kerrigan might
actually change that maybe this will
maybe we will see their first finalist
who knows
the first event dignitas played under
kerrigan's leadership was mlg's aspen
invitational where device demonstrated
that he was capable
of playing on a whole other level trying
to see what advantages they can find
and there it is they're gonna spot one
plan that's gonna cue the aggression to
get the trade here it goes device gets
the shot up to pronounce he goes down
from heaven
that's an opportunity now with ten
seconds left bomb goes down
one-on-one against olofmeister still
hasn't peaked and all he's gonna do he's
gonna try and hold it he's behind the
boxes
oh no peek out sooner is he going to get
him he fakes off of it
olaf so smart but does he have the
defuse he does
not he couldn't hold it long enough he
does still get some shots and device
just waiting it out pronax gets them but
there it is device pops out the teamwork
absolutely brilliant they take him down
and it's all grims he'll walk in device
on him as well
man oh man device is playing absolutely
excellent today they would assume it
would cover them off and they haven't
dropped the second one at the top of the
electrical
carrigan's gonna mow them down they're
in full position it's match point
can the favorites the tournament
favorites go home empty-handed
nobody would have predicted it dignitas
showing off
some incredible new form under the
leadership of kerrigan
will win the first award at x games
metal lebrons
after a third place finish dignitas
emerged from aspen as one of the most
promising teams in the world
and device one of the most promising
players it came as no surprise then when
several days after the event it was
announced that the danes had opted to
leave dignitas
in favor of team solomid whose offer was
alleged to be one of the most
economically enticing
across the entirety of cs go they were
talking to like three or four
other organizations and they wanted to
go with the best and highest offer
possible
so they put all the organization all the
organizations against each other to
just have a huge bidding war whoever
offered them the most appealing package
were able to get them so when we went in
we actually increased compensation
above all board because we were super
aggressive with getting into the scene
so we pushed pricing percentages to an
all-time high like we took like almost
no percentage it was like really little
and on top of that too the salaries that
our players were getting it was also one
of the highest salaries and most
aggressive salaries of that time
within two months tsm were facing off
against the best teams in the world at
2015's katowice major
and it was here where device proved that
he wasn't just capable of beating the
best
but downright styling device he should
know
he sees alois while he wants to see if
there's another one he could kill he
spots both of them he gets oh my god
that is insane takes down alvin
what a next level play he had them lined
up for
execution yet despite their best efforts
they only managed to get as far as the
quarter-finals
and from that point on device started
developing a reputation
for falling short at majors but
regardless of whether tsm won or lost
device always managed to put on a truly
staggering performance
here make that one device the last man
holding in the corner first kill goes
his way they line up for him
triple kill and taz is now very low as
well
situation is turned in the blink of an
eye eight seconds left
and device could he have just pulled an
olu he needs to get the quad and he's
gonna get it he is gonna get in three
seconds
if possible the ace for device talk
about the comeback
and as their star players dominance
began to surge
so did tsm's results the team went on to
amass six
first-place finishes between katowice
and the following major in cologne
including four consecutive tournament
wins and yet
come cologne 39 seconds and they're
gonna
once again rotate back but this time
with a bit of a twist this kerrigan is
moving up into
ct spawn he's gonna the tides are happy
that should have definitely been a kill
nbk up here he drops cajun
oh no not like this it's a 2v5
enemy they're punishing tsm capri goes
down
and it all comes down to sipnicks here
1v4 he's got 15 seconds and k
united danvy they make the grand finals
here
in cologne in spite of floundering at
the major tsm picked up right where they
left off and were quickly establishing
themselves as one of the best teams in
the world
and device was a big reason why in the
two months following cologne he went
from being tsm's most statistically
impressive player
to the single most consistently dominant
competitor
across the entirety of counter-strike
what's interesting is he manages to come
dominate with consistency it's not just
with crazy games it's that he's always
there
in the game and he's always putting up
these frags and giving you a chance to
win
doesn't matter who he's playing this guy
dominates against
all competition and always gives a
minimum of a very good performance
that's why he's the best in the world
this is where devices for me he set
himself apart from all these other
players and as a result he's a key
reason why tsm
is poised legitimately to be the winner
of the next major
and going into the third and final major
of the year it finally felt
as if device was slated to earn his
long-awaited title after finishing first
overall in the group stage tsm should
have had no trouble disposing of nip
in the first round of the playoff
bracket but then
they come through the window forest is
gonna be there she's the gun barrel get
right getting another headshot here it's
now a double kill he's looking
for just a bit more he's reloading he
ends up going down sip with the double
end
now it's the two versus three and duprey
and this techniques they've got
more pressure than they've ever had on
them here's freiburg spraying through
the smoke it's gonna take down one
dupree goes down and csm
they drop out nip they're gonna be in
the semifinals once
again in the months following their
disappointing finish at collusion of
poca the discussion surrounding tsm's
inability to close out a tournament
became the talk of the town for all the
wrong reasons
is there was there some truth to the the
claims like when thorin would say oh
you know some choke in the semis or when
people would say oh we can expect them
to choke now
is that just you know is it happenstance
when you lose in those situations is it
nerves
people like to claim things on behalf of
the team and
when people say we choke i would agree
it was 2014 but
not in this year i think it's just silly
to say that because
it's hard to just state it as a joke
every time and people
keep doing it and it is like you don't
really feel the nerves anymore you just
lost the game because you played poorly
and they played better and it didn't
help that come the end of 2015 an
antagonism that had been going on for
several months
between the team solomid organization
and the danish roster they'd enlisted
came to a head the danish squad came to
me they're like hey
andy i want to really focus on
performance and not do these sponsor
things i was like fine don't do it for
this time but make it up later
but the thing is that it never ended up
being made up
so we had all these things that they had
to do but they didn't end up doing it
but because the players had such
aggressive percentages on winning
and performing they focus on that and so
things got to be really bad with our
team because
they didn't fulfill their services which
i felt like behind the scenes that's a
really fair reason for me
to you know look to part ways with our
cs go team
dissatisfied with both tsm and the other
orgs they were in discussions with
device and his teammates felt as if
there was no place they could go
that would satisfy their main criteria
putting the player's
interests above all else and after years
of playing together they developed a
clear idea
as how a team ought to be run so after
parting ways with tsm the players spent
several weeks as the unsigned question
mark
before unveiling themselves as the
self-made self-owned super team
they'd long dreamed of becoming astralis
i can say that astralis was underway
like way back even in maybe start
october
when we started getting closer and
closer we we wanted to see if
our own organization could match
what we could get from other
organizations and it basically could
it makes more it makes more meaning for
us to play under australis now than it
would be to play on another brand
but despite their explosive launch
astralis kicked off 2016
somewhat haphazardly after only securing
top four finishes ahead of the year's
first major
the danes entered the event only to be
confronted with a sad
frustrating reality they hadn't shaken
their tendency
to choke when it mattered most spots to
jump again what a shot reaction device
goes down
guardian is so slick and cajun beat
needs toward him but he's got into the
underpass problem is he's let two go by
him zeus and edward
they're timing up middle he's gonna be
spotted down by dupree but they've got
so much control so much information
and they're just tearing them apart it's
down to just cajun b and dupree
that's cajun as well gonna fall and i
dare say it it's over
navier in the grand final the second
straight time
and the look on device's face he's had a
shocker every game to finish things off
here at the major
astralis were only able to secure third
fourth in columbus a disappointing
result
considering how long they'd straddled
the threshold of greatness
the community had even started to refer
to astralis inability to reach a major
final
as the semi-final curse it felt like
just seeing everything crumbling in the
same way that it has done before
kind of was kind of a setback in a way
that
i didn't expect and it made me like
emotional because i was like you get all
of these depressing thoughts that all of
the work i have done has not paid off
looking back at it obviously you can
take a lot of positive things from
even the laws and yeah it's
definitely pretty much why i was sad
like feeling the
disappointment in yourself and liking
the whole team as well
but little did the danes know things
were going to get worse
before they got better within a month
astralis had swapped longtime rifler
cajun bee for kiarby
a talented young star whose nickname in
the danish scene was little device
but because kiarby qualified for the
upcoming cologne major with a different
team
he was unable to compete with astralis
in need of a stand-in astralis turned to
someone whom to vice dupree and zypix
had always admired but were never
afforded the opportunity to play with
reputed danish igl glaive
and yet in a tragic turn of events
dupree was struck with a debilitating
case of appendicitis
midway through the major forcing their
coach sonic to play
on his behalf it felt as if device and
his comrades were encountering a string
of bad luck
and it reflected in their play four on
five now it's still vertus pro they
haven't committed but now they're going
to come towards this outer bomb site
here come the smokes it's all on this
defense
sonic glaive carrigan will be the first
in line but
can they stop what's about to come their
way neo takes a step out carrick and
greece with a smile but his tabs
and his tats all day that's two there's
snacks coming in with one of these left
sidniks
in a horrible situation bialy's already
on the hunt
and you can see them looking for it and
the spray comes in ziplex knows his days
are numbered but he's still fighting the
good fight but it's at
after a tough match against astralis who
fought with sheer
heart great determination anything you
could think of they put it up there
but it wasn't enough it would be
five months before astralis got another
shot at a major title
and device's danish ensemble had been
tasked with climbing out of one of their
worst slumps
despite having a myriad of experience
astralis were simply
incapable of coming together as a team
ultimately their problem wasn't skill
related
it was an issue of mentality after three
months of disappointing finishes
the danes made the drastic decision to
sell their in-game leader kerrigan
to faze clan astralis enlisted glaive as
their full-time replacement
but more importantly they collectively
decided that it was time to confront
their so-called
semi-final curse and made the pioneering
decision
to hire a sports psychologist my name is
mia stellberg and i am a sports
psychologist from finland
first we started off working with the
team spirit then of course i do
individual work with them because all of
them have their strengths and weaknesses
as players in general i'm trying to
teach them to be mentally more stronger
and also how to handle pressure and then
just like that astralis performance
skyrocketed
the team went on to earn top four
finishes in the next four tournaments
they played in
including the ecs season two finals
where astralis finally overcame their
demons
going around the back of the site rush
can't do anything about it three players
left to stop another
from winning etf season two makes one's
on fire he's in trouble
the boy's getting traded still alive
now's the last man standing but he can't
do it astralis
are your ecs season two champions 2016.
they've done it james they've finally
done it
let's try to put themselves back up
there with a massive
tournament victory and they did it in
the most incredible fashion
with glaive at the helm and both device
and krb firing on all cylinders
astralis sailed into 2017 with a cargo
load of confidence
and come the end of january all eyes
were on astralis
as they entered eleague's atlanta major
as favorites
after a middling group stage device
found himself facing off against a
simple lead navi
in the first round of the playoff
bracket and with the match being hailed
as the tournament's true finals
the danes knew that losing was not an
option
device though got a lovely angle but can
he find the heads he can
then there's another one there goes
simple it's 15 seconds again the bomb
needs to go down and just running into
the crosshair and he's delivering
every single time four kills for the
fights he wants the fifth he wants the
eight's not gonna get it overseas
he's got two more players to take down
the glaive towards bank
supports towards the truck he's gonna oh
he's not at the wrong angle
and that's it game one's gonna go the
way of australism what a message they
have sent to navi
this is not gonna be good for edward
he's not looking the right way and
hit from two sides that wants the
sandwich oh no
it's looking very grim for simple and
flamey can they do it simple it's the
first one
flamey though he's under pressure and
simple's head comes clean off
flamey to deliver but three points of
hell and astralis
have done it
by the time they advanced to the semis
they'd amassed enough confidence to need
only two games to put an end both to
their opponents
and to the so-called semi-final curse
this time it's perfect disco's got his
back turned he's ready for it but he's
gotta hit shots hasn't
lineup's there for dupreeh he's got two
what a play glam's got
olaf he's got the high hp but he has it
off he's missed shots
that could have cost him it does what a
shot from crims
fnatic in the most magical way or
pulling it back but look at kirby
right time right place and astralis get
19 in overtime
to take map one astralis overcoming all
odds
and the curse that has always been their
problem it's crimson it's one to go it's
only dennis remaining desperate with a
bomb and 15 hp caught out blinded up and
here he's got him
and that is a huge huge relief but
they're not done these guys mean
business they knew coming into this
tournament they had one goal
they're the favorites for a reason for
the first time
ever device had made it to the finals of
a cs go major
and after spending nearly four years as
a top-tier player he had no intention of
disappointing his team
his fans or himself the only thing
standing in his way
was a notoriously explosive virtus pro
toppling them would be no small task
a fact which became painfully obvious in
the third and final map of the series
here comes the vertis pro push snacks
gets the refract on dupreeh that's a big
start now devices in the back line with
the awp
but he's gonna get smoked off he can't
get the shot 13 seconds they're planning
the bomb right around but
is there anyone there to stop it it
doesn't seem like it and now the retake
is on
that device missing shot up the shot
this is painful to watch especially
because taz was so close he could hear
the scoping and that sets it up
perfectly bp not gonna make any mistakes
they aren't peaking him
until he got him looking the wrong way
zip nick's
not gonna make it happen in the end and
another crucial round picked up here for
voters pro
a 6-0 lead now for them and yet despite
finding themselves in a seven round
deficit astralis began to rally
he finds he's creeping in gets the flick
on knee one takes him down and suddenly
they're in a two on three tazz still up
there and they're looking for him to try
and see if they can close him out
as he peeks he's going to get taken up
by kiev and now it's just be ali in the
corner they're going to get the full
retake
nobody even goes down now at this point
and he's going to be able to spot zip
next for free but that gives it away
those tracers you can see dupree trying
to close in but taz
will hit the headshot into the 1v1 we go
in so little time can't be sticking to
the fuse and he's going to hit the top
unreal up by e box all the molotov
coming in the free
nearly getting the spray if you aren't
going to go down anywhere in this
neighbor dropping neck
past you and taz are left into two on
four astralis that bring you back
this is incredible are we going to see
it our straw is going to break the curse
are they going to win
their first major the first time they're
in the finals and their first title will
find out because the action's on and
gary opens it up takes down
the all right snacks in an uncomfortable
position he goes down with the max 70
can't make it happen finally pasha
coming in with the refract but he's down
the bomb has been picked up by the free
they get the spray neal takes one and
how's it there and astralis they win the
first major championship
16-14 against fluttershy
device and his danish brothers had
finally reached the peak of competitive
counter-strike
but little did they know they wouldn't
be able to stay there
for very long
astralis continued to put up excellent
results in the months following the
major win
including a victory over faze clan at
iem katowice
it was in the wake of that tournament
that device began to shed light on some
recent stomach problems he'd been having
having been diagnosed with a hiatal
hernia a condition whose seriousness is
amplified by stress
device was instructed to attend fewer
events and was even hospitalized in
november
after pushing himself too hard coupled
with kiarby's lackluster play
results steadily declined and the
situation was clear
astralis had been relegated back to a
life of semi-final exclusions
after months of teetering on the edge of
irrelevance the danes exited 2018's
boston major without even making the
playoffs
and in a shocking turn of events kiarby
announced that he had left astralis
for north when i got the news 100 i was
still on vacation i was
obviously shocked i didn't know what to
say right we i thought that
i feel still feel like we're good
friends but in all honesty we would just
have appreciated a conversation about it
because also
still at the moment we really don't know
why he left so yeah it's a bit sad but
i hope that he does well and when i see
him at events we say hi and
i still feel like we can get a good
relationship out of it but
it's just yeah it's just sad to feel
betrayed
in some way with few choices for a
replacement the danes brought in magisk
to mark the beginning
of a new era the one of the goals we had
when we started astralis 2.0 or whatever
you want to call like when we brought in
magisk is that we wanted to we wanted to
we wanted to have an error like we
wanted we wanted people to
like analysts and other players and like
recognize
recognize us for our style and creating
the game like creating the maid and
stuff like that when we got magisk on
the team
our goal wasn't just to be the best team
in the world we wanted to
create something more than that and
and that's why we've been performing so
well for so long time it's a kind of a
hard thing for teams to do to become
number one
it's not the hardest part but it's
staying at the top spot
and as luck would have it magisk turned
out to be the perfect fit
and it was around this time that the
danes began to make strides in terms of
what they could do
outside of the game in order to improve
their in-game performance
finding out the demands of
counter-strike was pretty
difficult because it's not like every
other spouse
after a talk then i've understood the
process of
aiming in my world it's a matter of of
understanding
how is your coordination in your
shoulder arm
how is your coordination your eye your
stability and the precision
in the neck and then we can see where
the
deficits are fitness was something that
device had always been passionate about
but it wasn't until his health problems
that it became his mission
to exemplify the importance of
maintaining mental and bodily health in
esports
since i come from sports physical
fitness was always a
normal thing for me to do it affects my
performance in
many ways i think the cardiovascular
part of it helps a lot with the oxygen
levels in your brain how long you can
concentrate and be focused and
it matters a lot in practice especially
because we have a lot of like long
practice
days and and then if you're not in shape
so to say you can be
really slow and for me and for the team
it's a
it's a key point for our performance the
danes will go on to secure top four
finishes at the iem world championship
before taking first place at dreamhack
marseille in april
these guys are looking spectacular right
now it's taken a while to get things
together
it's been so long since their major
victory but i think they're on path to
another one now
this is the best-looking astralis since
that time and one
that could conquer 2018 once again
ladies and gentlemen
your champions at dreamhack masters
marseille
it's astralis
the danes went on to earn six top four
finishes in their next seven events
three of which they won and by the time
the london major rolled around
it wasn't even a contest astralis were
odds-on favorites to win it all
and on the back of some truly impressive
performances by device
niko going to be taking down make this
nice shot from device this is madness
device hitting one more shot for the
triple
in close range just no scoping important
try to hold the take on a device
might force them back but right through
the confidence they are the only one
that can maybe save them
definitely going to be in trouble it
goes down to device i was going to say
there's no way he doesn't live in this
situation but gets away only to fall to
division
one player and survive and there goes
zip knicks but device without taking
him out it's gonna be no problem black
boosted up big kill from device
even chopper is gonna go down he has
broken
and look at device they managed to
traverse the playoff bracket without
dropping a single map
come the grand finals they were shoe-in
simple
and flamey that's all that's left
between australis and the major
simple on the high ground with the
season and surely he's going to get
taken out oh there's a gift he could
pick up an ak this might not be over yet
there's no kid though they've got to go
far simple the second one they have to
keep going they've got to charge forward
he misses the jump
flaming now with the five seven he's
baiting the pair of short b is red
touching the bomb are they going to peek
holding it now
and there is it it's just out of play me
it's not gonna happen
australis they never faltered
they did not relent they have brought
counter-strike to levels
we've never seen before this is their
era
this is the team to beat to be called
the best
you'll face it london major champions
it's astralis
as soon as they'd earn their second
major victory it became clear that
counter-strike
had entered the era of astralis from
this point on
the dane's domination was utter and
absolute
they went on to secure eight first place
finishes over the course of nine
competitions
and became the first recipients of
intel's one million dollar
grand slam the grand slam is theirs esl
season eight as well and that's why
they're considered the world's best
right now to be honest henry i
absolutely can the anticipation was that
this was always theirs they were the
heavy favorite coming in
and they show off why back-to-back ecs
back-to-back pro league marsai
season seven chicago and now for the
first time ever at home season eight
i've strolled into the champions league
pro league and for the first time in
history the best of all [ __ ] times
until grand slam is destroyed
[Music]
over the course of a single year
astralis went from down and out
to quite possibly the greatest roster in
the history of cs go
during this time device fulfilled hopes
defined expectations
and overcame a debilitating illness he
retook the counter-strike scene by storm
earned more mvp medals than any player
in history
and solidified himself as one of the
greatest counter-strike players
in the world when you retire
many years from now what do you want
people to say when they talk about the
device
in many ways it's difficult to talk
about device as an individual
to talk about him outside of astralis
to reconcile his superstar status with
his inherently selfless
supportive and team-oriented attitude
i think device has a really important
role not only like performance wise that
he's
like by far the star player we have the
team and he's uh he's fighting to be the
best player of this season at least
i think the way he uh he motivates the
team when we when we play we're feeling
down like the way that he
tried to keep everyone on positive
mindsets
i think is really important and there's
a reason why i've been playing with this
guy for like six years so
yeah we tend to keep this core for as
long as possible i love my team
i don't think i could do this with any
other five guys
honestly if we weren't like such a great
family and friends and so nice to each
other i don't think
it would be possible for me to do this
at least unlike most top tier talents
device never set out to become the best
player he set out to build
the best team the irony is that in
achieving the latter
in becoming the figurehead of one of the
greatest lineups of all time
he's put himself into contention for the
former as well
but that's not how device wants his name
to go down in history
i think one of the one of my like my
main identity is
the physiological part about this game
it's also being aware of
what you're putting your your body
through um
the level of stress but also doing it
all with a smile on your face
this is um it's a lifestyle that's not
for the
weak-hearted and all honesty i just want
them to
remember a great guy that had
a good vision on on on the physiological
aspect and obviously a champion
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button